[Music]
yes it is
I love my mother
[Music]
so let's get after it and have us
some good [__] bread
go [__] bread uh oh boy Chris Chris
is uh
um
[Music]
except that I had to accept because I
was gonna kill everybody uh including
myself things can consume you Italians
are so passionate and I really
what no mercy come on
Italians are so passionate
these are dying on my thigh you know we
noticing that
look man sometimes we get spicy like an
Arabia what do you want
so wait a second
well then you know Chris on a real
Italian would never kill himself Chris
was so Italian that he wanted to kill
everybody and then himself yes Chris I
don't know that's an Italian trait or a
[__] Psychopathic trait yeah I wanted
to commit family Annihilation because I
lost my job that's really uh you know
stable
I had to accept we should red flag Chris
Cuomo I mean seriously doesn't have any
guns or anything making statements like
that
you know I was in my lowest point and my
wife said Chris it's gonna be okay and I
said [__] I'll [__] kill you
because I was gonna kill everybody uh
including myself things can consume you
Italians are so passionate and I really
had to fight against that because
you know just like you did I got too
many people counting on me
no no no no the bird's dead
he seems like someone that gets into
fits of Rage well
uh this isn't responding to more YouTube
comments
project
[Music]
so happy hey everybody a little
something special YouTube comments hey I
asked for it now you guys
that people brought up some nice some
not so nice that makes Greg very happy
but that's what we're all about here at
the Chris Cuomo price is everybody still
here
several weeks ago where you came across
a wounded bird and you picked it up and
you you let it go this user says need
bird update please thanks in advance
says what happened to the bird Cuomo
shout out Alan Cox these are our people
these are our people
oh we finally got it we finally got our
moment I didn't think he was ever going
to address this um junkie says can I get
an update on that bird hey did that bird
survive or what a lot of people want to
know what happened to that bird
oh no look at his face oh no the bird
didn't make it it was the paper taper
you've got work to do because now you
have to take down our original Chris
Cuomo for a thing or a chop add this to
the Chris Cole if we need we need a
super cut
guess what matters and as I'm walking
see this guy
did he kill the bird for this is he
gonna snap its neck
you're not gonna kill oh my God I was
dude I thought he was gonna Frank
Underwood this bird in front of us I
thought he was just gonna kill him
sometimes the most merciful thing you
can do is to put it out of its misery
that's what a man does as he's puffing
his cigar he cigar chomped in his teeth
snaps his Bird's neck
yeah does that make you uncomfortable
what do you want to murder the city or
in pain that's what a man does
Buona not a little Andrews he picked it
up before and then he realized I should
film this and he put it back on the
ground to start filming the video to
figure you know he did that well this
bird's dying you know he did by the way
it's a baby bird so if it has a broken
wing you should get it somewhere
immediately right now because it could
die of pain and shock probably cold
probably cold
we may probably call a vet drop it off
at a vet bro I I don't know if we get we
don't really get a resolution to the
bird I I've looked on his channel unless
he's updated something very recently
I don't know if this I don't know if
this bird died or not Chris what
happened to the bird I mean how long did
he walk with this [__] injured bird
20 minutes what do you think the over
under is that he just kind of put it in
his pocket and forgot about it a week
later he puts his hand in that pocket
he's like oh [__] I knew I had to do all
the sun is dryer it's just like Thump
Thump Thump he's like what's in there
please drop that bird
he still has it in his pocket it's
Friday goes to get a cigar and he's like
I forgot about the burger a little
skeleton now Stray Cats following him I
wonder why my jacket was stinking away I
just had I just had ROTC comments coming
from RT's comment what happened to the
bird Chris
that's all we need I need to know
you never told us you never told us what
happened to that bird I like to know
what happened to the bird I need
everybody to ask him what happened to
the bird there you go here you go I took
a that's a good point here you guys let
me put the postal link here and this
isn't this is just asking because we
want to know the well further please ask
Chris there's he got something it's his
latest walk and talk
um ask him what's up with the bird we
want to know what happened to the bird
because I really want to at least his
next year be like a lot of people leave
comments about the bird let me tell you
what happened I cooked them up in a
risotto it was delicious a little pesto
sauce
by the way if you want to refresh I
think we got some more oh really okay
let's check it out I think more people
are asking maybe we'll go we'll go let's
go to news first what do you say 103. do
we ever find out what happened to the
bird I care about the bird infinitely
more than I care about Chris where's the
bird that was you merge uh uh let's see
do us dolphin uh you put the bird out of
it did you put the bird out of his
misery uh greasy PanAm hi Chris do you
still have the dead bird in your pocket
what did you do with that bird Chris I'm
dying to know what happened with this
bird what did she do that bird Chris I
love it okay this is perfect good job
guys
we need an update yeah we do need to
find out when you know what's going on
with the bird I follow I saw these two
Knuckleheads made a move made up made a
video about me
what was this about
I'm nice to everybody that's all this
bird talk
honestly man this is how the movie The
Cell started and I don't know if we
should be diving into this this is that
was a terrible movie what you do what
did you do with the bird Chris tell us
it's fate where's the bird Chris sir
just wanted to know the welfare of the
bird kind of hungry that was Frozen
Thank you Frozen well Frozen no come on
Frozen it's a little dance that question
dear Linda your boobs are incredible and
then the first thing the other grass
sizing is I says I gotta ask you a
question why is there a dead bird by
your keys
no fight now it's a skeleton why is
there a little tiny bird skeleton on the
floor I was supposed to do that but then
I got to the gym and I forgot I was leg
days the whole thing don't worry about
it it's about me
about anybody that's where's the bird
Chris
Bird that's the only thing we want to
know
where's the bird hey Chris you coward
why don't you play our clip on your show
answer some more questions like yeah
where's the burger where's the bird
where's the [__] the bird yes what
happened to the bird
[Music]
the bird was delicious oh he ate the
birds
with Chris Palmer we got a couple things
first off first what happened to the
bird
of the bird socks that was us that was
this show that was nobody else because
later on Fifth quartering or 50 other
people are gonna say that was me that
was us
we willed it you could see the date you
could look at it it's gonna be like you
know I'm very passionate about it this
is ours
I'm sorry who are who is that who are
you who is that
freaking beans
wait and I was talking about boring
Jeremy no yeah you think boring oh yeah
he's saying boring Jeremy he's singing
beans yeah okay
[__] we did it we did it we did it I'm
so happy I'm so happy and he's not
thrilled
we're in your algorithm Chris
forgive me but
how would I know
you're the one that picked the bird up
wait what you ate it I know he ate it he
ate it he ate the bird this is amazing
this is freaking nuts what's what's what
did he say
how would I know how but you
so he just he just
so he didn't take the bird you ready
here we go forgive me but
how would I know
what happened
because you picked up an injured bird
paraded it around in a video and then
just ended the video now the reason I'm
thinking you would know right Chris and
maybe it's just me maybe I'm maybe I'm a
little [__] up you know
um but if if I were to find an injured
animal see Chris I'm sure you have a
household pet so I'm sure you have a
neighborhood vet or you probably have a
couple vets in the area that you know I
would go to one of these uh pet
hospitals and then I would bring them
the bird and here's the thing Chris they
wouldn't charge me you could just take
an injured bird to a pet hospital and
very likely they'll fix the bird's wing
and then let it go he's he never said
what he was going to do with it all he
said was that he picked it up and now
he's like how the [__] should I know I
was probably still in my pocket next to
my cockies
I can't believe this to the bird what
bird you're a bird How would how would I
know I was walking on the street and it
came like out of this tree wait he's
trying to answer what happened to the
bird before he found it you dumb [__]
were wondering what happened to the bird
is the bird okay now you [__]
what happened to the bird he's going how
should I know I don't know I found a
bird on the ground I was saying since
the video you [__] he knows that he's
this is honestly
we're under you Chris we are on to you
Chris what happened to the bird Chris
answer the question Chris guys bird gate
just got serious
now now now I have to say Chris that
until you
I'm gonna phrase this carefully until
you are able to clarify what happened to
the bird since the video I have to
assume that you did something sinister
to the bird that's all I could think of
now what do you hiding Christopher
what's your problem with birds bro
the side I don't know where it came from
because I wasn't paying attention birds
are just Nature's airplanes I don't know
if it had been hit or if it was falling
or if it was really young I don't know
but it was in front of me
and I'm a big put out of its misery deal
like even with like
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh oh did he
whack it
did you whack off the bird did you jerk
the bird off
did you have the bird come on your face
Chris and you kill it can you go back a
few more seconds trying to really
dissect this here I need to know what
happened to the bird it's very simple I
was your favorite horse
had to get rid of the bird King on the
street and it came like out of this tree
all of a sudden where it came from the
side I don't know where it came from
because I wasn't paying attention I
don't know if it had been hit or if it
was falling or if it was really young I
don't know but it was in front of me
and I'm a big put out of its misery deal
like even with like mouse traps yeah
yeah Frank Underwood right you just
strangle the [__] dog episode one
hey look in his house for a bunch of wet
iPhones we'll just like take meister and
my glue traps or like throw them in the
garbage I I think that's inhumane uh I
think catching mice is inhumane I don't
so
I picked up the bird
and I figured I'll just hold it a little
bit while I'm talking because it was
kind of still there
I have a house with a lot of Windows and
even though we've put lots of stickers
on the Windows birds still fly into them
usually when they fly into the window
it's over he has one of those annoying
houses right that's like built into like
the Wilderness oh yeah it just murders
hey hey
hey pessy and virgin remember the
episode of American Dad where Stan had
that Native American that built his home
into the mountain and birds just kept
smashing bald eagles kept smashing and
dying into it
grabbed grab me a cup of that please
especially if my wife's dog gets to him
so I picked up the bird and I was
walking with it and while I was talking
it started to move more I kind of closed
my hand around it uh to give it a little
bit of warmth and was holding it against
me right it wasn't that cold out but it
was a little bit and it was uh you know
shaking a little bit and then it came
more into it and started to Peck at my
finger pick at my finger and I was like
all right this is good at least it's
starting to come back a little bit and
I'm not like a bird person but again I
have had a fair amount of experience
with birds flying
you're not with the chicks playing in
the things because of my house and it
really started to get restless and when
I opened my hand it flew close to the
ground but then up away and into a tree
he killed it he killed the bird the bird
but we were watching the video you that
was at the beginning of the video 20
minutes later at no point in the video
did the bird fly away did you kill the
bird Chris he killed the bird he killed
the bird
everyone tell Chris Cuomo Proof of Life
where you killed the bird that's what we
want to know because let me tell you
something this is the flying up in the
tree thing isn't true oh you're you're
gonna go ahead no go ahead if the flying
in the thing the tree thing isn't true
then my my brother being a sex pest
isn't true tell the kids on Lemon
stuff's not true it's not true tell the
kid
you saw Don Lemon started that Morning
Show and the ratings have gone down
instead of up since he joined it's
hilarious Day show yeah I swear to God I
just read an article
but it's easy to bring the here's the
thing I can already tell you what's
going on
that time slot
is for like light-hearted Fox and
Friends like programming fun stuff
supposed to be gutfeldy people sitting
around going can you believe that one
you know and don lemon's bringing that
sanctimonious nighttime [__] that's
like wow you know it's just uh it's just
tragic that we don't do more about guns
and it's like it's three in the
afternoon on a Sunday dude you know
mostly anybody that's tuned into CNN or
has it on in the background and they're
just your background noise ironically
ironically you know who would have
killed in a morning show Chris Cuomo if
you just if you let them show up with
like a Tommy Bahama shirt you know what
I mean lapel might show up like hey what
are we talking about football we're
talking about four I'm gonna go cook a
Rachel Ray come here we're gonna make
spaghetti like my Nona used to make Hey
listen coming up next this is fun I
can't wait for this one we got Guy Fieri
here hell he's gonna teach us how to
make treats for your pets so you can
take them to flavor town we'll be back
yeah
that's all you need in the afternoon
it's eating easy light [__] I know
and that was the last time I've ever
seen it
so no no correspondence yeah until it
came to my house and knocked on the door
uh which isn't easy because I had to use
its beak so I couldn't understand what
it was saying because well you're not
good at improving huh she's knocking and
trying to talk the same time two talks
at the same time you would knock and
then you would open the door and talk
no he's trying to he's trying to claim
that he is he can't understand the bird
we know you can understand the bird
Chris we already read an entire stretch
EBT thing about you understanding the
bird Chris took the chat CPT thing from
us and he's not now now he's using the
bird drama as content Chris we want
producer credits on your show we want
producer credits on your show let's talk
Chris come on our show let's have a
conversation and by the way Chris I
don't speak cat either right like I
don't understand what my cats are saying
when they're meowing right but I can
account for them right now yeah right
like Clarence is laying on the couch
Louie's laying in a box on the floor you
see how easy that was I don't need to
speak their language to answer the
question numerous Radio Cats other in
the living room no
no impossible and I said what's up bird
and I said oh you remember me
I said yeah you know it wasn't that long
ago and how often do I have this kind of
exchange with a feathered friend and
did you hear that did you hear that with
a feathered Fred my fine fabulous friend
oh Christopher
I'll make your theme song I'll make you
a new theme song I'll be like Chris
cobomo Chris kawomo hey Chris Coloma
with you there you go there you go now
you got a theme song this [__]
meatball chomo [__] stealing all of
our [__] and he's poking at us he's like
haha and nobody's ever gonna know yeah
they will now there's the link search
for this video by the way it's the
latest one Chris Cuomo responds even
more YouTube comments and make sure you
get in his comments and make sure you
let him know to give ROTC credit revenge
of this is credit you can even tag our
Channel tag our clip Channel if you want
Cloud inundate him and let them know
that the chat CPT thing is ours the
[__] fine feathered friend thing he
did is ours and the bird thing is ours
we're in your [__] head now aren't we
muscular John that's why you took us off
the off your little uh radar with your
YouTube friends don't worry though the
last one I put up on the main channel so
that one did show up
but then also from now on he's our new
Stuttering John he's muscular John
muscular John
muscular chomo John these two [__]
fat balls Fat Ball loses is coming
it's common yeah yeah went off and he's
like I gotta fly in another recent
listener calls episode you were when
that's the end of that
Jesus Christ chomo did you know the bird
came up in this no no I swear to you I
this is what I'll tell you I'll tell you
my thought process from beginning to end
so here's what I did I I all I want I
want all I wanted to do was play the uh
this still I'll kill you and everybody
clip that we played but then I'm like
well [__] let's see let me check on his
channel let's see if Chris Cuomo's is
something else we can make a whole oh
like segment we could clip out of it and
I all I saw was a title Chris Cuomo
responds even more YouTube comments
that's it and I did I found it live when
you saw me find it I had no idea